today I want to talk about two of the
most under utilized words in the
dictionary that actually get other
people to want to help you I'm Patrick
bit of your host of ITT McLean recently
one of the leaders that I code she
called me and she said Patrick I'm
struggling with something I said what is
it she said I'm struggling with getting
people to want to help me I see so many
people that getting other people to want
to help this one person out or this
other person out how come I'm not
getting people to want to help me and I
kind of know her personality she's too
bossy and she is you know way way too
demanding with people wanting to do
things for her but this was a way I
wanted to see what she was gonna think
about it you know what I thought about I
thought about the people in my life that
were the best of getting me to want to
help them on and you know what was so
unique if you make a list of people you
like helping and list the people you
don't like helping the list of people
that we like helping they usually use
the two words that the list of people we
don't like to help that don't use you
know what those two words are they say
words such as please can you do this for
me one word is please the other one when
you fulfill the request they're making
they actually say thank you I appreciate
what you did for me so there's a level
of gratitude that people want to work
with this person and help this person
win because they say please and they say
thank you I'm not talking about you
talking to your coach or your mentor
who's challenging you to improve and
expecting you to get better I'm simply
asking when you're dealing with people
and our relationships and you want them
to help you out use the word please and
use the word thank you you have no idea
how much weight is behind those two
words so let me end with saying please
subscribe to this channel and thank you
for watching and commenting on this
video
Abraham
so recently LeBron Jamis was gone for
this one gun